[Musique]
à
salut les terriens ce soit en p1 nous
accueillons stéphane bern
[Applaudissements]
c'est un bon soir bonsoir or publier un
nouveau livre vous travaillez sur france
2 rtl est justement vous êtes ici ce
soir pour nous faire le jingle rtl
[Rires]
alors un indice alain duhamel n'y est
pas arrivé mais je suis incapable de
mémoire barbares amp amp un pimpant
[Applaudissements]
ont fait de nous accueillerons xavier de
moulins
présentateur du journal de 19h45 sur m6
le journal comme dit la pub en avance
sur son temps et xavier nous donnera le
résultat des présidentielles
xavier nous parlera aussi de son
deuxième roman
ce parfait ciel bleu publié on s'est
tous assis vous dirait de retrouver pas
mal
toujours en p2 nous accueillerons bruno
solo
solo ne parlera de la pièce qu'ils
jouent en mai au théâtre antoine inconnu
à cette adresse je crois qu'on peut
rassurer tous ceux qui ont vu la vérité
si je mens 3 ça n'a rien à voir
enfin on paie 3 après le zapping et
guillon nous acquérons notre invité du
samedi 20 heures ce soir philippe
croizon amputé des quatre membres il a
réussi à traverser la manche à la nage
voilà l'émission s'appelle salut les
terriens et le groupe les gréements de
sortie
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est van der rebond soir vous
faites partie des animateurs les plus
polis et les moins drogués de la
télévision et févier je ne sais pas on
sait pas gok mérite d'abord on m'a
jamais proposé de drogue en voulait non
merci j'ai très peur en fait j'ai peur
d'aimer ça donc j'ai jamais touché alors
dont ni la télé tout le monde dit que
vous êtes sympas accessible bienveillant
et vous savez que vous gâcher le métier
avec vos conneries parce que moi tout le
monde me dit à berne au moins lui il est
sympa c'est pas comme vous
mais vous avez du métier veut que j'ai
encore le temps d'apprendre c'est dur
d'être sympa tout le temps oui c'est pas
toujours simple vous prenez des produits
non non non non c'est pas ça mais c'est
plus efficace ouais parce que sur le
long terme les gens vont [ __ ] la paix
quand
vous avez eu énervé une fois l'an
dernier pendant le news show sur canal
vous avez réagi à un propos homophobe de
louis nicollin le président du club de
foot de montpellier et vous l'aviez
traiter de gros cons vous connaissez des
gros mots alors oui j'en connais
quelques-uns mais écoutez franchement je
ne supporte pas le racisme
l'antisémitisme l'homophobie le sexisme
moselle et oublier la guerre quand même
non parce que je pense que nous on peut
se comporter un peu mieux surtout on
peut donner l'exemple ouais au début
nicolas oublier le traité de cuistre de
malotrus ils n'auraient pas compris il
aurait pas nombreux en effet pas alors
généralement vous êtes donc très polis
toujours impeccable dans la tenue des
fois vous êtes un peu foufou vous mettez
un
j'ai toujours
oui pour vous le jim c'est ce qu'il ya
de plus mineures plus foufou d'accord
alors représenté à la bonne heure sur
rtl oui le jingle tintin tintin rtl il
est midi un très bien
[Applaudissements]
qui va passer de longues jambes et
sonatel alors l'après midi sur france 2
vous présenter comment ça va bien une
émission dans laquelle des chroniqueurs
test du truc et viennent en parler
autour d'une table vite aller chercher
où cette idée parce que
on est venu me chercher avec cette idée
à dakar c'est un programme plutôt
d'accueil plutôt divertissante par le
mode beauté déco santé bien-être enfin
tous kim heger est ce que j'aime c'est
que c'est une émission de proximité
ça m'a rendu aussi plus attentifs à nos
contemporains aux terriens justement
avec six villes et j'ai trouvé ça pas
mal parce que c'est vrai les émissions
de l'histoire que je fais d'été secrets
d'histoire je suis là perché comme ça
dans un ailleurs un autre temps dans des
palais inaccessible ça crée pas un
climat de 2,2 de marange caravane du
peuple est exactement alors que ma
nature vous le savez cévennes plutôt
près des gens moi j'ai l'image peut être
du type qui fréquentent les grands de ce
monde mais moi je vis avec les gens je
ne monte pas dans un 4 4 blazy un peu en
fait j'aime beaucoup votre émission
franchement ça donne envie d'être
chômage pour voir la regarder
il ya par exemple des femmes enceintes
qui après le m'écrivant dix ans le voilà
j'étais allongé pendant deux mois je
vous ai regardé tous les après midi je
sais pas ça donne envie d'être enceinte
non mais c'est une mission très
difficile à faire parce qu'il faut pas
que les retraités ou le chômeur sans
normes
j'aime bien me lancer des défis sur
france 2 vous présenter aussi secret
d'histoire j'adore ces les puces les
soirées spéciales plus les grands
directs et vous avez pourtant déclaré
récemment dans vsd je ne suis pas en
cours je n'ai pas pour le moment la
faveur des patrons de france 2 qu'est ce
que ça serait si vous l'aviez quand même
non écoutez la faveur salaire je fais
jamais partie des animateurs qui sont en
haut de la liste dans les petits papiers
des dirigeants seraient les
incontournables on parle jamais mais
c'est pas très grave en même temps parce
que je suis atypique alors ses fans il y
aura faim mais un secret d'histoire
consacrée au jubilé de diamant de la
reine elizabeth 2 vous avez tourné à
windsor à buckingham et sur le yacht
briolin britannia absolument ça c'est un
scoop et alors on découvre qu'en fait
brouillard il ya tout le décor
historique dans les palais mais quand
elle choisit vraiment l'ameublement très
cheap assez moche ah oui à ces traits
noirs ah ouais bah c'est très anglais en
fanfare dont ces saumons vers amende
c'est serré ce bébé
alors vous ferez à nouveau équipe avec
marie drucker le 3 juin oui on va te
présenter les festivités en direct de
londres may notre notre parrain surtout
qui est karl lagerfeld bruit va nous qui
va nous aider pour le documentaire il
est absolument génial vous savez bien
limité la gare
je me connais
brian duensing à la terre
alors last but not least vous publié
chez albin michel
le destin d'une reine c'est un livre
autobiographique
vous avez je cire les pompes je ponds
plaisir si
je ne me prends pas pour une reine
c'est un beau livre est rempli de photos
commentées qu'illustre la vie
d'elizabeth 60 ans de règne mesdames et
messieurs mais c'est pas tout le monde
qui arrive et surtout pour glisser un
autre chef d'état qui avait 60 ans au
pouvoir alors c'est vrai que c'est un
pouvoir symbolique plus politique mais
et qui a la cote de popularité
équivalent à son âge sa popularité ne
s'est jamais et nous a même cédé moment
des vagues de diana mais mais c'est
incroyable un chef d'état comme celle
qui résiste à tout un alors elle voit le
premier ministre mardi soir à 18 heures
oui elle a une influence sur la vie
politique et l'âge est certaine
influence parce qu'elle a de
l'expérience un penser que les
prévionnistes que ce soit tony blair ou
david cameron ont toujours que nous
quelle c'est un peu la grand mère de la
nation britannique don qui lui demande
conseil et puis elle connaît toutes les
lois et donc forcément quand le prévenu
est arrivé et du matériel cette loi là
le mollah pourquoi vous utilisez ça
forcément il est quand même un garçon
est pris en faute l'avantagé qu'ils
n'ont pas besoin de faire des élections
présidentielles coûte beaucoup moins
cher j'ai fait le calcul c'est la
monarchie britannique coût de 60
centimes d'euro par an et par habitant
alors que la république française coûte
à peu près 3 euros appareils
oui mais voilà alors elle va battre un
record leur corps de son aïeul et
modèles la reine victoria
elle va le battre le 9 septembre 2015
elle aura 64 ans de règne oui c'est
super la misa bête de la wii alors que
magna veut c'est tout pourri
oui mais je sais dire je les plus usuels
que j'ai vu est venu l2 alors vous
n'avez jamais assumé stéphane vos
origines juives ou dit mais pourquoi
vous dites ça parce que vous allez gérer
ça ne fait pas partie de mon royaume ce
n'était que des interdits pour ma bar
mitzvah je n'arrivais pas à lire
l'hébreu non mais c'est vrai beau que
j'ai eu des problèmes avec ça mais
aujourd'hui j'assume parfaitement mes
origines le problème est absolument pas
là mais ce que je dis simplement je ne
veux je n'appartiens à aucune communauté
oui je supporte pas le communautarisme
c'est parce que voilà c'est pas dans mon
esprit j'allais dire républicain on veut
toujours vous ramener à vous aurez joué
c'est comme par exemple quelqu'un qui
s'appelle comme l'a dit le chef d'état
d'apparence musulmane quelqu'un qui a un
nom qui s'appelle rachid ou oum ahmed je
lui demande pas d'où il vient pour moi
il est français comme moi voyez ce que
je veux dire je considère mon
intégration pour moi elle est naturelle
alors vous n'avez jamais bien assumé non
plus vos origines modestes l'or mais
c'est bien comment ça mais j'assume pas
fait non
premier rendez-vous le comte de paris le
père prend un jour de congé pour vous y
conduire et vous monter à l'arrière de
la voiture pour faire croire que c'est
votre chauffer c'est vrai qu'est ce que
j'ai fait pourquoi j'étais raconter ça
un jour non mais c'est vrai que ce jour
les j'étais con mais j'ai pris une belle
leçon et mon père m'a donné une très
belle leçon et vous apparemment
c'est l'intégration par la culture chez
nous mes grands parents étaient des
modeste artisan vraiment ils n'avaient
pas le soul n'ont pas pu payer des
études à mais à mon père qu'il ya eu des
bourses il a réussi à faire une belle
carrière et il nous a vraiment payé à
mon frère moi des études fabuleuse mais
je veux dire par là que j'ai absolument
par ont des origines modestes mes deux
grands pères étaient et être d'origine
vraiment jour-là dix ans dans ce jour là
j'ai déconné parce que je j'ai fait le
même amalgame que tous les gens qui nous
regardent et qu'ils à la monarchie
forcément c'est les gens qui se prennent
pour des qui ont besoin de se reposer
alors que le comte de paris était en
train d'écouter la valise verte et
affectivement et que sa maîtresse passer
l'aspirateur et et qu'après ils m'ont
tendu 1 du café avec une avec du sucre
et et elle lui ai dit la pince
monseigneur
c'est le premier souvenir que des faits
authentiques
et les jeux de mots pourris
en revanche dans le magazine têtu sont
de mireille dumas vous avez parlé de
notre homosexualité parce que vous en
aviez assez des rumeurs sur votre
hétérosexualité
j'ai toujours dis une chose je ne mens
pas ouais la seule chose c'est que si on
me pose la question je réponds je ne
veux pas que ce soit un étendard oui je
ne vais pas voter en fonction de celui
qui dévoila en revanche je ne supporte
pas l'homophobie je trouve que c'est
indigne c'est insupportable et je me
bats non nicolas 12 nicolas d'où je me
bats pour le refus je cite une
association pour parce que il ya aussi
beaucoup de famille vous savez quand il
des camps leur gamin à 15 ans découvrent
qu'ils sont homosexuels les parents les
[ __ ] dehors et à 15 ans vous n'avez
pas vraiment de ressources pour vous
ensemble ou le refuge d'où le refuge
alors au monde cette action vous avez
déclaré
j'avoue que j'ai toujours un préservatif
sur moi au kazoo au kazoo quoi
au cas où quelqu'un m'en demandez au cas
où
je vous rassure ça se met pas sur la
tête et au bout de est-ce que c'est là
encore vous rencontriez le prince albert
non
mais m'arriver
bruno solo habitudes
[Musique]
ramon soir les terrienne rebond soit les
terres nous sommes toujours en compagnie
de stéphane bern
[Applaudissements]
bruno solo
et de boulin
[Applaudissements]
wen selon don soir soir thierry vous
êtes ici ce soir pour répondre à la
question que tout le monde se pose en
vous voyant dans cette émission encore
bruno solo
en fait ce qui fait dire à nos amis
téléspectateurs c'est qu'après dix
invitations dans cette émission on a
droit à une invitation pour la promo de
son choix d'accord rien
en ami vaccia je préférais
aller vous aimez bien commencé mon trône
car
oui bon la famille ça va ça pousse ça va
douze ans ils sont heureux d'être les
enfants et je suis heureux de leur papa
alors j'ai vu vous avez été récemment le
parrain du rallye aïcha des gazelles
mais vous y connaissez kw avons
traversée du désert qui cesserait yvan
le bolloc'h on comprendrait
aussi quand même alors vous qui êtes le
père spirituel divan oued un mois et de
bons que ça commence à se savoir comment
osez-vous par les divans comme ça après
la le gitan du finistère il casserait
les carabins
mais dans sa caravane
et un très joli salon où il joue avec
ses camarades il doit être retourné en
ce moment il a joué et calamity jane ya
pas très longtemps il doit être montré
qu'ils nous regardent voilà alors vous
paraît mais également le concours les
nouveaux talents du rire le 29 mai va
chez un peu plus que le parachute
coproducteur et le co-fondateur de dieu
yves estivals l'humour en capitales qui
existe depuis six ans maintenant vous
pas ramener aussi un site de poker en
ligne vous paraît les bobards c'est fini
ah bon ça c'est fini je trouve que vous
pas renier beaucoup mais j'ai là d'un
parent on avait vous appelez donne solo
alors la vérité c'est que c'est ici ce
soir pour nous parler d'une pièce que
vous jouez à partir de mercredi au
théâtre antoine avec samuel le bihan la
pièce est super c'est inconnu à cette
adresse de catherine kressmann taylor
ans le pitch aller alors vous donc
d'appeler max eisenstein d'un juif
américain qui correspond avec son ami et
associé allemand martin schulz eux au
moment de la montée du nazisme alors au
début les lettres sont très touchante
pleine d'émotion et petit à petit les
échanges s'échauffent on comprend que
martin ait pris dans la machine
infernale du nazisme et les deux vont
peu à peu s'éloigner alors lui travaille
pour l'état allemand il ira jusqu à vous
dire je ne veux rien avoir à faire avec
les juifs mise à part des virements
bancaires quand même ils disent à son
meilleur pote à son associé oui c'est
pour ça qu'elle est la pièce elle a une
portée universelle aussi forte c'est que
s'imaginer que celui que vous pensiez
connaître celui composé nier dont vous
louiez le les qualités les valeurs tout
d'un coup vous trahit parce qu'ils
s'éloignent de vous et il est rattrapé
par l'idéologie la pire qui soit
tout d'un coup comme ans deux hommes se
comportent face à ce cas de figure c'est
un peu l'histoire de dévisser moon et
dieudonné finalement c'est
alors blague à part c'est exactement ça
alors je croyais pas si bien dire j'ai
vu le spectacle avec elie semoun ya
quelques jours je lui ai dit ça il m'a
dit c'est vrai qu'elle me touche
particulièrement parce qu'ils étaient
plus que des potes quoi ils étaient
comme des frères ils ont été
merveilleusement amis et tout d'un coup
il ya un éloignement qui s'est fait la
grangrène s'est installée dans l'esprit
de dieudo même si je tiens à dire
qu'encore aujourd'hui dieudo est un
artiste immense maintenant voilà céline
était un immense écrivain et puis
relancé l'homme qu'il était donc ça
c'est la pièce à cette dimension
universelle et là où elle est géniale
aussi c'est que christine taylor elle a
aussi cette qualité d'écriture qu'on les
les romanciers anglo saxon il ya une
dimension presque de polar c'est la
nouvelle parfaite c'est dix neuf lettres
la pièce est très courte elle dure une
heure c'est à 19h au théâtre antoine
voilà et vous y êtes à partir du 2 buts
quand vous dites que inconnu à cette
adresse est une pièce génial vous
bluffer ou pas passé comme vous êtes un
champion du poker la highway mais là non
non non non une pièce génial au sens le
plus le plus strict du terme alors bruno
on dit que la semaine prochaine nous
passer le week end en hollande
bon je vais pas me cacher de mémos et
avait dû alors xavier de moulins re
bonsoir bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
ou plutôt javier deux moulins d'un mieux
de beaufort encore un one et samoussas
vous à
damas je connais bien xavier de moulins
dame yeux de beaufort aux très bonnes
familles anciennes est ce que c'est bien
comme niveau et ce car il sait très bien
que ses fesses et provinciales
c'est palois voilà la seule fierté que
j'ai par rapport à ma famille c'est les
origines étrangères de ma famille oui on
va dire sans du sang monténégrins
exactement fait des slaves du problème
de ma mère et puis c'est d'espagne et
des philippines du côté de mon père
ouais et s'est fait à un étranger et
voilà je suis un étranger c'est pas bien
intégrés
enfance modeste
à meudon la forêt à trois blocs de chez
malik oussékine vous êtes vous alors
vous dites nous étions neuf à la maison
alors on anémie hausse qu'il ya la mer
déjà beaucoup de blaye maintenant j'ai
vu la mer pour la première fois en huit
ans ouais mais pas beaucoup de blé mais
beaucoup d'amour du couche à compenser
et c'est vrai que du coup pas de pas de
besoin plus que ça exprimer et puis je
vous dis on ne mangeait grandi dans la
mixité vont jouer au foot sur le parking
avec des copains de tout de tous les
horizons des noirs des arabes des juifs
et puis et puis moi et voilà les deux
puits depuis ma femme m'appelle l'aristo
calmer
alors vous voyez vos parents mais vous
écoutez salut à toi des béruriers noirs
ouais assez votre hymne aux fins quand
même il y avait deux dans un esprit de
révolte voilà qui me confessais bien à
l'époque festif révolte festive alors
c'est l'époque de doc martins des manifs
contre la loi devaquet
ensuite après le bac fait hypokhâgne
khâgne maîtrise de lettres à la sorbonne
et un d eux s s de télécommunications à
dauphine qu'est ce qui vous a pris mais
en fait j'en ai marre de l'abstraction
littéraire je venais de faire une une
maîtrise sur le sentiment de l'amour
dans le théâtre de beckett oui et je me
suis dit finalement comme ça c'est
formidable maintenant la dernière bande
et où des boules jours mais j'ai envie
d'un peu de réelles et puis je voyais
arriver j'avais des copains pirates
informatiques qui avait fixé les comme
ils ont commencé à montrer ce que
c'était qu'un ordinateur et je
connaissais absolument rien et je me
suis dit c'est marrant il ya deux
révolutions qui arrive il va falloir des
interprètes un peu comme dans les
guerres et donc j'ai décidé de
déchiffrer tout ça est donc servi après
mais on est d'abord à 24 ans vous partez
retrouver votre petite amie à new york
et la mère de votre petite amie vous
envoie dans une communauté de moines
franciscains dans le bronx ouais mais je
voulais absolument que je kiffe sa fille
est allée vous purifier l'esprit dans le
bronx il ya des franciscains à un arrêt
là j'ai fait une rencontre incroyable
mois qui a été élevé dans la foi le
catholicisme etc j'ai jamais rencontré
dieu malgré l'éducation et donc j'étais
très agnostique 13 ans 13 ans curiosité
je ne vis pas dans le bronx en plus et
ben si
il arrive jusque là il est en effet en
robe de bure en sandales été comme hiver
et et s'occupe des autres avec avec
trois mots clés obédience chasteté et
pauvreté oui et j'ai rencontré des
profils de gens absolument un
commentaire vous deviez rester deux
semaines neutre est et trois mois comme
un appartement alors au retour justement
ce reportage évidemment et publié dans
la croix ensuite fait des piges sur
internet étaient exactement ensuite des
sujets dans nulle part ailleurs dans
plus clair en 2005 vous êtes chroniqueur
toujours sur canal dans on n'est pas des
anges avec maitena biraben et en 2006
paris dernière sur paris première
toujours ce qui ramène tout à lui
en 2010 le jt de m6 à 19h45 alors
pourquoi vous avez arrêté par dernier a
voulu retrouver une sexualité normale
j'ai jamais perdu ma sexualité normale
ah ouais ouais super début j'imaginais
même pas ça existe le truc le plus
dingue que vous ayez vu en faisant
parler dernière écoutez c'était les
normes par tous dans un loft j'étais
donc le seul à billets s'étaient tous
soutenus avec des masses et puis une
femme servait de buffet vivant et je
parlais avec elle on a parlé météo
vacances scolaires
et les gens comprenaient pas et elle non
plus elle était en pleine action
évidemment et on se rend compte qu'en
parlant d'autres choses avec des gens en
action les gens ne perdent jamais le
nord ils ne demandent pas ils ne
demandent pas mais ne perd jamais le
nord voilà qui font des dons en même
temps ses fans vous connaissez départ
toujours à tout le monde
[Rires]
mais
on m'avait jamais dans les fêtes ça va
alors avant sa main sur m6 sa part
valérie damidot qui veut des jeunes avec
vous la cantine
mais j'aime beaucoup valérie super
copine ya les jeunes pas la comptine en
revanche sont ceux des dîners très sympa
non ça se passe bien votre jt cartonne
en deux saisons l'audience est passé de
2 à 4 millions 5 ouais c'est non
kobe alain publié pour beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
pour beaucoup c'est la salopette des
bogdanoff sur la gueule sa chance alors
voilà non mais jusqu'à la chambre s'est
passé quand même à l'ancien publicitaire
que je m'adresse à vous non mais c'est
le très bien cette campagne si elle
avait été ratée ce que je me suis fait
vannes et là dessus un jeu de voiture
ban empêche comment par l'emploi j'avais
trade et ça toute ma vie sa jambe est en
avance de quinze minutes exactement
qu'est ce qui va se passer dans 15
minutes adam 15 buts là je ne sais pas
on va accueillir peut-être une autre
personne le cgv
[Applaudissements]
on compare souvent votre diction lente
et votre timbre à ppda un dvd avec des
cheveux quand même
grâce à dieu alors comme de penhap
j'écris des livres ouais peut-être vous
les écrits mais
le premier en 2011 s'appeler un coup à
prendre c'était la chronique douce amère
de la vie d'un père séparé de ses deux
fillettes garde alternée c'est très
touchant alors le deuxième roman
s'appelle ce parfait ciel bleu c'est
publié au diable vauvert ans ce sont
toujours les aventures d'antoine duhamel
ouais alors vous dites il a mal quand il
regarde en arrière et peur quand il
regarde en avant il marche comme un
crabe un oeil devant un oeil derrière ce
qui l'empêchent d'avancer
alors un jour liquide nappe sa
grand-mère mouna que vous un fauteuil
dans une maison de retraite ils
l'emmènent une dernière fois voire la
mer en normandie et elle lui dit vit au
présent ouais c'est la réponse elle me
présente guillaume maison ce qui s'est
passé à peu près rien y faire c'est le
principal défi on ne sait pas donc voilà
pas jouer aux espions pas de nostalgie
juste impressionnant ici et me voilà
alors là on en profite on dit rien
on vit au présent bail sont souvent
sommaires dida
si on arrive à rentrer en conscience
avec soin toi qui passe son temps à
faire plein de choses en même temps tout
d'un coup tu t'arrêtes était là mais je
perd jamais le nord comme la dame nature
mais ce que j'écris très très bien que
des merdes on va faire un big up pour
xavier de moulins
[Musique]
c
félicitations et voilà on passe
maintenant l'actualité de la semaine
avec l'édito de blacko un essai
elisabeth lévy directrice du magazine
causeur et chroniqueuse d'on refait le
monde sur rtl que nous retrouvons
sur ce bateau après le magnéto
[Musique]
le 21 avril 2002 quand le pen père
s'était qualifié pour le second tour la
classe politique a exprimé son rejet du
front national le 22 avril 2012 il s'est
produit quasiment inverse quand le pen
fille ne s'est pas qualifié pour le
second tour toute la classe politique a
exprimé son soutien aux six millions et
demi d'électeurs du front national oh
les pauvres électeurs du front national
ce sont des gens qui souffrent a dit
sarkozy je n'aurais pas le droit de
m'agresser à la souffrance ce sont des
gens en colère nous devons les entendre
a dit holland la colère elle est là par
rapport un quinquennat d'échec
d'injustice d'incohérences en bref on
s'adresse aux électeurs du fn comme à
des victimes je peux parler au petit je
veux parler aux sans-grade ça alors
c'est justement l'expression qu'à
employer le pen le 21 avril 2002 pour
s'adresser à ses électeurs vous les
petits les sans grades pauvre petit sans
grade avec la crise il souffrait
tellement qu'on ne peut pas leur en
vouloir d'être en colère depuis le temps
qu'ils se faire marcher dessus il
aimerait bien à verser rôles en
piétinant quelqu'un à leur tour mais
acquise en prendre deux tiers des
électeurs de le pen soutiennent en
priorité son combat contre l'immigration
mais curieusement c'est dans les petites
communes rurales que le vote fn a le
plus progressé ce petit coin de nature
est le cadre idéal pour vous présenter
le nouveau front national dans ces
petits coins de france bien peinard où
les gens circulent entre leur maison
leur boulot et le supermarché sans
jamais croiser un immigré sauf le soir
bien sûr dans leur salon il suffit
d'allumer la télé pour entendre ce que
répète le gouvernement depuis cinq ans
s'inquiète pour l'identité nationale on
polémique sans la viande halal on débat
sont les mosquées où les femmes voient
les pauvres électeurs du front national
il y aurait fallu remplacer leur télé
par un aquarium ça les aurait fait
bouger du canapé il serait sorti se
promener dans la nature et aujourd'hui
ce serait après les voies d'eva joly que
tout le monde traite en train de courir
et en plus vous contribuez au respect de
l'environnement voilà c'est très vite de
blacko un mise en image de julien gracq
elisabeth les bons soirs j'ai directrice
de la rédaction du magazine causeur
chroniqueuse d'on refait le monde sur
rtl et vous publiez la gauche contre le
rêve chez fayard bienvenue parmi nous
merci mais alors marine le pen a gagné
le premier tour a beau l arbitre le
deuxième tour en 2002 tout le monde
tapait sur les faits non la démocratie
dix ans plus tard tout le monde à
commencer par sarkozy du corps après au
nom de la compréhension de la souffrance
de ses électeurs
le cordon sanitaire cher à chirac a
sauté le front républicain n'existe plus
réécoutez le cordon sanitaire a quand
même eu l'effet brillant est la
conséquence
formidable d'amener le front à peu près
de 5 à 18% de l'électorat donc peut-être
ne serait ce que pour des raisons
concrètes et tactique peut-être
faudrait-il s'interroger sur
l'intelligence de cette politique
déjà ça c'est la première chose mais
cette affaire de les pauvres on les
plans les victimes ça n'a pas été vrai
que des électeurs du front national je
trouve que ces élections étaient la
victoire du dolorisme alors je sais
qu'il ya des gens qui s'ouvre mais même
les gens qui souffrent ne sont pas
réduits alors souffrent vu leur vie
n'est pas que souffrance ou les mêmes
les gens qui ont des problèmes d'argent
qui ont des problèmes de chômage ce ne
sont pas uniquement ça et dans cette
élection on ne s'est adressée qu'à cette
cassette affecte la dette et tous les
électeurs c'est nous on nous a plein je
commence à en avoir un peu assez et je
crois que beaucoup d'électeurs du front
national bon sinon aux identités
nationales ne vote pas marine le pen
parce qu'ils souffrent pas seulement non
mais aussi parce qu'il n'aime pas les
arabes oui alors on peut le dire comme
ça mais il ya des tas de raisons
disons de vouloir la réduction des flux
migratoires y compris parce qu'on aime
les arabes et qu'on veut que ceux qui
sont chez nous soit intégré la question
qui est posée ces deux effectivement de
préserver un certain art de vivre qui
est menacée peut-être peut-être ou
peut-être pas ça ça devrait être discuté
donc je trouve que de les renvoyer tout
le temps à ça c'est à dire si vous
voulez réduire l'émigration si vous êtes
un [ __ ] de raciste c'est quand même un
peu ce discours lent si vous voulez
qu'il ya d'abord empêcher toute
discussion parce que évidemment quand on
vous renvoie dans l'enfer du racisme n'y
a plus de discussion en fait et qui a
fait monter le front national vous
marine le pen m les arabes n'ont ni
d'abord aimer les arv ça veut rien dire
je veux dire moi je n'aime pas j'aime
pas les français ou les arabes on
rejette des jambes et de la tête à des
locations d'aimer ou de ne pas aimer je
trouve est pas une bonne question police
a dans la tête des gens tout cas que
dans la tête des vecteurs c'est une
vraie question parce que le sens de la
nuance que vous développez ce soir je
suis pas persuadé que tout le monde
puisse le comprendre il un moment hélas
en politique le débat ils se réunissent
ils se résument premier tour le bouc
émissaire c'est le riche d'accord on
taxe les riches deuxième tour les appels
a dit que ça divise d'immigration donc
les migraines et donc au bout d'un
moment la vision elle devient simpliste
alors est ce que le monde n'est pas
aussi intelligent ne verra plus les
moyens de se défendre que on reprendre
cette famille nologie l'arabe parce que
effectivement quand on dit immigrés dans
ce pays on le sait plus en plus et dans
beaucoup de pays d'europe candy migrer
le texte sous jacent c'est à ben on
parle pas de migration polonaise
italienne portugaise roumaine rom
another year arabes et noirs non mais
bien sûr mais voilà oui à ces noirs vous
avez raison sur l'asile de la même voilà
donc c'est vrai que de toute façon on
joue un jeu dangereux les thématiques
hrs sémantique aujourd'hui font
n'importe quoi et je crois que nous
avons tort de voir du racisme partout et
en plus là je trouve que la gauche a une
grande responsabilité dans une chose
vous voulez c'est que d'un côté elle
exalte la différence en permanence et
moi par exemple j'ai appris que il y
avait une élection ou métaux à france
télévisions on organise un casting de la
diversité c'est à dire on recrute des
animateurs sur des critères raciaux tout
en france en 2009 fait hurler personnage
avait parfaitement voilà c'est d'un
autre côté on dit le premier qui verra
la différence sera arrêté alors les gens
deviennent fous parce qu'on peut pas
dire à la fois qu'il ya une différence
c'est qu'il faut la célébrer et d'un
autre côté n'existe pas est ce que vous
pensez donc que le cordon sanitaire
tchérattes chirac a sont évidemment
qu'il a sauté mais ce que c'est une
mauvaise chose pour vous qui est alors
moi je vous dire mais ça n'engage que
moi mais j'aurais toujours du mal
toujours du mal à envisager qu à
situation égale deux mecs dans le même
ville dans les mêmes que dans la même
précarité avec la même insécurité avec
le même sentiment que c'est difficile il
y en a un qui fait entre guillemets
l'effort peut-être de se dire que c'est
pas si simple que ça et qui va peut-être
pas voter pour un parti qui désigne un
bouc émissaire et un autre dans les
mêmes conditions à des conditions égales
qui va voter pour le truc alors moi
comme je ne suis pas un homme politique
j'ai pas besoin d'emploi quel employé à
langue de bois ça me fait chier ça me
fait chier de savoir qui en a qu'on la
paresse intellectuelle de dire car je
veux aller plus vite je vais voter pour
sua depuis comme ça il va le foot dehors
c'est parce qu'à cause de luxe ou
malheureux et d'autres qui auraient même
conscient de sa liste c'est peut-être
pas si simple et je t'aime pas voter
pour les extrêmes les extrémismes c'est
une solution de facilité et pourquoi
parce que la politique maintenant série
slogan c'est les phrases rapide c'est
des images et voilà on essaye de de
focaliser de stigmatiser de diviser très
vite ça l'a toujours été un peu mais
c'est devenu tellement ça aujourd'hui la
politique la prie dieu la passion du le
truc qu'on prend dans l'instant et au
tac c'est aussi l'art de mai jusqu'à
mantes années plus tard dans l'année
plus de maintenance et où les politiques
n'a plus cette capacité cette faculté à
élever les gens l arabe est ce le genre
il ya une responsabilité des politiques
à ne pas vouloir un peu éduquer les gens
leur expliquer que c'est pas si simple
moi j'ai adoré la politique je suis
vraiment contre l'anti parlementarisme
primaire mais je suis tellement d
enchanter à gauche et à droite je trouve
la paresse des politiques vis-à-vis des
vrais problèmes et à lévis vraiment ça
me je vous assure que sa machine est
restée sur le nas et agit que je n'avais
pas vraiment pas de vote sa série castle
nous écoutons stéphane darbelet voilà
non juste dont tout le monde parle de
défendre par exemple la tradition
l'histoire l'identité française il y
avait un roi qui s'appelait henri iii
qui a simplement décès que toute
personne qui mettait sur le pied sur le
sol de france était suggéré nicole
sujets du roi de france appelle le droit
du sol mais et des gens qui se réclament
aujourd'hui d'une longue tradition de
viande et veulent remettre en cause le
droit du sol moi je ne comprends pas ça
alors ils avaient tous salué dans votre
livre le virage républicain laïc et
étatiste de marine le pen je ne le fais
pas comme ça je dis je prends acte des
discours je ne dis pas que tout ce
qu'elle dit est républicain moi j'ai été
absolument ou très de rage quand elle a
parlé l'immigration aux dix ans tous les
meules et mohamed merah qui déferle sur
nos côtes ce que j'essaye de dire c'est
que l je ne fais pas de d'affect là je
fais pas de morale elle elle veut
arriver au pouvoir à mon avis elle sait
qu'elle n'arrivera pas au pouvoir sur
les thématiques de son père alors la
question que je me pose c'est que tant
que son père donc le surmoi de son père
plane je sais pas ce qui va se passer
mais ce que je pense et qu'elle essaye
en gros de réoccuper l'espace qui a été
laissé en déshérence qui était celui de
l'ancien rpr elle refait surtout dit
bruno mégret et en fait on se rend
compte que finalement la théorie du mes
nerfs à l'époque vous remet plus ni
moins celle qui est en train de faire
c'est-à-dire de planter la droite pour
créer un grand parti populiste
fréquentable allez on se lasser ni oui
ni celle là elle n'a pas inventé elle a
juste copié un spectacle j'ai fini le
projet de ce que jean marie le pen
appelait le félon et donc elle a trahi
son père en disant cette approche parce
qu'en 2002 jean marie le pen qui fait la
gueule il veux pas le pouvoir et il dit
mais qu'est ce que vous avez remarqué
qu'à chaque
fois qu'elle s'approche du truc qui sort
un gros truc sur les actionnaires fois
sur brasillach alors oui non le l'échec
de mélenchon avait du succès de marine
le pen est-ce que ça prouve pas que la
lutte des races finalement et plus
efficace la lutte des classes c'est vrai
que la lutte des classes tandis qu'elle
n'existe plus elle n'existe plus en tout
cas dans le débat mais elle existe à
l'évidence dans la rue elle existe à
l'évidence dans l'est dans les faits
voilà quand elle a lu beyrath je pense
pas qu'il ya encore aujourd'hui une
sorte de racisme primaire comme on a pu
connaître dans les années 10 20 30 et
tous vraiment à penser que le noir est
inférieur que la ramena c'est pas aussi
et c'est pas aussi simple que ça j'ai
envie de dire presque hélas parce que
bon voilà des racistes pur et dur il y
en a quinze jours directement les gens
mais je n'en fais plus d'excusés les
électeurs du front national ils disent
qu'ils aiment tant les arabes tout
simplement c'est donc aujourd'hui c'est
un vote de contestation
ce qu'on a mis un s que c'est pas encore
une fois je crois que a ils tiennent à
préserver ce soit tant de choses qu'ils
pensent menacé alors pour conclure parce
que finalement sarkozy était le meilleur
candidat pour la droite à cette élection
qui aurait été le candidat de la droite
vous imaginez réellement vous croyez que
c'est sérieux alain juppé faisant
campagne pour la présidentielle ça vous
semble je pense qu'il a pas flinguer la
droite sarkozy finalement
je sais pas si la droite a besoin de
sarkozy pour son époux nicolas sarkozy
aura pas mieux fait d'écouter borloo
plutôt buisson tout le monde dit que la
stratégie buisson a échoué moi je me dis
que peut-être s'il n'y avait pas eu la
stratégie buisson on aurait eu pour le
coup un 21 avril fillon dit le contraire
oui ayant dit le contre elisabeth lévy
merci d'abord et merci à jérôme
aiment-ils votre livre la gauche contre
le real chez fayard alors avant de
conclure cette paix de retour sur la
soirée électorale de dimanche dernier
avec l'édito de blacko deux mises en
images de julien gracq
[Musique]
normalement france télévision nos
diffuse jamais d'émissions de
téléréalité sauf bien sûr s'il s'agit de
l'as far et des présidentielles ils sont
dix ils ne seront plus que deux bah oui
une émission où les téléspectateurs
doivent voter pour éliminer huit
candidats sur dix dès la première manche
faut bien reconnaître que c'est de la
télé réalité à 20 heures la révélation
des deux finalistes d'autant qu'à la
manière du loft les candidates sont
placés en permanence sous l'oeil des
caméras de france 2 voilà c'est juste
une image du candidat socialiste rien ne
doit échapper à l'oeil de big brother
bravo en tout cas dans notre jargon
c'est ce qu'on appelle une exclusivité
après la télé-réalité c'est toujours le
même principe il suffit d'en fermer des
gens qui ne peuvent pas se blairer dans
un studio truffe est une caméra ils
passent leur temps à s'engueuler sous
l'oeil ravi des téléspectateurs
mêlant les journalistes de france 2
apporte un vrai plus c'est sur
l'interview acrobatique monsieur sarkozy
en france 2 s'il vous plaît un monsieur
sarkozy parce que poser des questions
sans intérêt à des hommes politiques qui
ne vous répond pas ça c'est un peu la
base du journalisme mais le faire en
équilibre sur une moto qui roule à fond
dans la circulation là c'est autre chose
oui on est avec nicolas sarkozy là il va
peut-être nous dire un mot c'est aussi
ça le service public tient à la bien sûr
on se moque n'empêche le public a adoré
puisque pour la première fois depuis 95
la soirée présidentielle de france 2 a
battu celle de tf1 alors on salue ceux
qui nous ont rejoints sur ce plateau
tout en gardant un oeil sur la voiture
de nicolas sarkozy parce qu'il va
peut-être redescendre s'invite pas
nouveau alors si vous faites partie de
ceux qui ont vraiment aimé ce premier
tour sur france 2 la voiture s'éloigne
le cdh remonter sur la moto se préparer
ou pour le second tour à une soirée
encore plus spectaculaire
voilà c'était la pile de santé bonjour
après d'affilée
l autre invité d'accord ce soir trois
ans amputé des quatre membres il a
réussi à traverser la manche à la nage
et latitude
[Musique]
bonsoir était rien bonsoir l'intérieur
nous sommes toujours en compagnie de
stéphane bern
javier de lula
bruno solo
et nous accueillons notre invité du
samedi 20 heures ce soir philippe
croizon bonsoir
or philippe le 5 mars 1994 they 26 ans
votre vie va basculer pour toujours
électrocutés par une ligne à haute
tension
vous vous réveillez à l'hôpital amputé
des quatre membres
et là vous entrevoyez à la télé une
image qui restera à jamais scotché dans
votre mémoire une jeune fille de 17 ans
qui traversent la manche à la nage et
vous vous dites pourquoi pas moi un jour
voilà vous le ferez 32 km 100 brasse en
jambes et vous racontez votre exploit
dans un livre publié chez jean claude
gawsewitch et intitulé j'ai traversé la
manche à la nage on en parle à 20 heures
que du bonheur en attendant jacques al
stéphane guillon
à bouche des femmes pour lyon
et on commence avec l'info principale de
la semaine carla bruni veut faire du
porte à porte pour soutenir son mari
il n'y a pas de vannes c'est ça la bad
[Applaudissements]
nicolas sarkozy a dîné avec les joueurs
du paris saint-germain ouais il a les
mêmes angoisses que perdre le
championnat finir deuxième raté toute sa
saison et puis si père sur le marché des
transferts à son âge avec son palmarès
on parle d'une retraite en italie chez
les bruni tedeschi
shopping sieste balade à vélo
il va se faire chier
après les appels du pied de nicolas
sarkozy aux électeurs frontistes et sa
volonté d'organiser un 1er mai louis
aliot s'est écrié il n'a plus qu'à
mettre une perruque blonde et la
panoplie sera complète eh bien
il faut comprendre les électeurs du
front national
sont des gens qui souffrent
alors c'est vrai que leur chef pose avec
des néonazis
danse avec eux mais souffre faut les
respecter et considérer les chouchouter
et peut-être leur offrir une coupe de
champagne un moment momo apporte du
champagne aux électeurs de marine le pen
voilà leur momo qui est ici depuis trois
générations
il va partir il va rentrer chez lui
non non non moi je resterai
momo il ya des gens qui souffrent ta
présence en france les fait souffrir
son petit en mal mais non mais moi je
reste ici je suis né ici mômes au
moment où quelqu'un qui a du coeur
on applaudit momo kemp à faire de la
peine aux électeurs du front national tu
prends ton plateau et tu prends ton char
t
[Applaudissements]
faut appeler eric besson pour qu'ils
s'occupent du voyage de deux mots en
plus ça lui fait des miles à chaque fois
christian estrosi accuse france 3 de
voler le contribuable sous prétexte que
la chaîne n'a pas couvert le meeting du
président à nice en janvier 2008 afin de
pouvoir assister à un cocktail organisé
à l'elysée estrosi avait préféré l'eau
et un falcon pour se rendre à washington
plutôt que d'emprunter le vol régulier
d'air france coût pour le contribuable
cent trente-huit mille euros en matière
de vol estrosi est un expert
[Applaudissements]
aia le premier bébé venu du froid est né
l'ovule de sa mère et le sperme de son
père avait été congelé
attention maintenant qu'il est né ne pas
m aya dans un congélateur
recongeler un produit décongelé c'est
hyper mauvais
démarrage à l'union du procès de guylène
collober qui à congeler le corps de son
compagnon
si vous voulez un bébé c'est le sperme
qu'il faut qu'on ne l'ait pas le
bonhomme entier
j'ai du mal en ce moment je leur donne
des conseils chaque semaine et ça
c'est dur et c'est
johnny hallyday qui doit 9 millions
d'euros au fisc a déclaré qu'il trouvait
françois hollande charmant avec les
nouvelles règles fiscales de hollande
pour payer 9 millions d'euros johnny
devra en gagner 36 charmant c'est le
terme qui convient hollande est charmant
la chasse au frelon asiatique qui tue
nos abeilles est ouverte ah ça c'est un
thème de campagne pour nicolas sarkozy
il n'y a aucune raison
le frelon asiatique est arrivé de chine
en 2004 de façon totalement illégale 1
les boat people de frelons viennent tuer
des abeilles française installée ici
depuis des générations
frelon asiatique très agressif
ibos 7 jours sur 7
la une face de citron
il sourit en permanence et toujours
l'air de
dessous de votre gueule et le soir
thierry ardisson le soir le frôle en
face de citron massacre des tubes de
barbelivien dans des karaokés du 13e et
bien ça c'est terminé c'est terminé
les abeilles français souffrent
elles veulent récupérer leurs ruches
faire leur miel - si je vais faire mon
miel
dimanche dernier elle m'a envoyé un
signal fort je les écoutais à la semaine
prochaine merci bon voilà c'est estevan
lyon
si la sienne
sylla
quoique
on passe maintenant à notre invité du
samedi 9
et
bonsoir je vous êtes né le 20 mars 1968
à châtellerault perdre au compteur mère
ouvrière chez aigle vos parents 18 ans
donc ils sont étranglés par
l'inexpérience les difficultés
financières il vous confie ainsi que
votre grand frère à vos grands parents
et c'est auprès de votre grand-père que
vous prendrez le goût de l'armée
à l'école c'est pas terrible à vous est
dyslexique et à l'époque dyslexie que ça
veut dire bon à rien oui ça veut dire on
s'occupe du poêle à fioul au fond de la
classe voilà d'accord alors vos parents
vous pousse vers un apprentissage de la
charcuterie enfin c'est ça vous fait
parler avec quoi l'étudiante a dit non
deux ans et après je me sauve voilà donc
vous devancé l'appel pour le service
militaire et vous faites un service de
longue durée dans l'infanterie marine
à 17 ans vous avez rencontré muriel qui
avait 15 ans vous dites en la voyant je
suis subjugué quand même temps je suis
très jeune mais bon le coup de foudre et
puis voilà quoi donc
alors la séparation est insoutenable il
faut attendre 18 mois dix-huit mois
après celle à qui et là vous trouver un
emploi stable aux fonderies du poitou
vous habitez une petite maison à saint
rémy sur creuse dans le nord du poitou
pas de salle de bain des wc dans la cour
l'humidité sur les murs on va vous êtes
jeune vous aimez brevet c'est la
première maison donc que tout est nickel
mais quand muriel est à nouveau en cinq
là il faut trouver une autre maison plus
grande plus confortable et le samedi 5
mars 1994 le jour du déménagement donc
tous vos amis sont là pour vous aider à
remplir le camion le premier voyage se
passe bien pause café avant de repartir
quand vous décidez de monter sur le toit
pour démonter l'antenne de télévision
vous dit pas question de la laisser aux
nouveaux occupants
on est jeune voilà à l'antenne ça
coûtait cher j'avais fait venir un
installateur et tout et je dis bon je
veux le récupérer pour une échelle dans
l'aluminium ouais et je me corde à la
cheminée j'attrape c'est quand elle
commence à déboulonner quand vous
redescendez du toit avec l'antenne dans
les bras vous recevez soudain un choc
d'une puissance il ou en fait il ya un
arc électrique qui s'est produit une
fois l'antenne une ligne à haute tension
qui est trop proche non ces trois
matelas c'est un m les chaussures en
caoutchouc donc tout va bien je tiens
moi je pose mes tibias et la contact
avec la terre ça me colle je suis 20000
volts alors là au premier choc vouliez
défiler toute votre vie ouais pour te
dit un moyen très courte vie 26 ans donc
c'est très court alors là soudain
deuxième choc des rides et sharp qui
fait en fait effet d'électrochoc c'est à
dire que votre coeur redémarre je
redémarre mais je reviens à la vie vaut
être et à partir de ce moment là je
perds plus jamais connaissance voilà
électricité est coupée mais quand les
agents de maintenance réenclenche non
courants en labs est électrocuté pour la
troisième fois et là je reste sous
tension voilà et cette fois ci alors
votre corps prend ce baraquement à
l'échelle se déforme et le goudron de la
route en bas fonds ouais même la ligne
téléphonique c'est de la chaleur passent
par ligne téléphonique et fait fondre le
téléphone qu'ils ont la maison tellement
la chaleur est dantesque pas alors voilà
vous vous réveillez à l'hôpital
un
mois plus tard vous voulez vous lever
oui en pleine nuit ouais j'ai soif moi
j'ai une terrible soit fait derrière de
la torture et ultime et un robinet qui
fuit un petit goût tu cliques club et je
dis bon aux siens je me levais jugé sous
évalué mais bon sang mais je vais me
lever à voilà melloul bord du 10 mai et
puis j'essaie de m'appuyer sur la jambe
mais je veux pas et la larme se met en
route et l'infirmière me rendors
accepted seringue magique pour que je
m'aperçois de rien là vous découvrez
l'horrible réalité alors vous voulez
mourir dans un premier temps on se
réveille on est on appuie bras on n'a
plus de jambes et on se pose la question
quel va être ma place au sein de la
société qu'elle est surtout ma place au
sein de ma famille est-ce que je vais
encore un père est ce que je vais te
recrute il a quelque chose il souffrait
le martyre car vous avez mal à vos
anciens membres ouais ça s'appelle la
douleur du membre fantôme journal mais
en ce moment on parle j'ai toujours mes
mains j'ai toujours mes doigts 1 je peux
jouer avec enfin voilà quoi mais c'est
une douleur qui est en permanence tout
le temps donc on fait plus attention et
un cerveau qui vous transmet toujours
cette voix là oui oui temps en temps il
envoie des décharges électriques pour
pour voir si les membres sont venus ou
quoi alors après il ya effectivement une
rééducation qui fait mal qui coûte cher
mais ça coûte très cher les prothèses
pour vos bras si 18000 euros
l'aménagement de la maison 13000 et la
voiture adaptée 31000 way mes parents
tout de suite et ils disent mais on peut
pas et on ne pourra jamais faire passez
donc ils ont réflexe de créer une
association est de dire voilà on va
créer des manifestations et tout on va
récolter des dons et grâce à eux je suis
une personne handicapée qui a énormément
de chance vraiment vraiment alors je
suis heureux parce que dès que besoin
d'un matériel taquet sont là ils
m'aident alors finalement vous revenez
chez vous alors au début vous avez
beaucoup de visites tout le monde vient
vous voir effectivement ça se passe
plutôt bien mais bientôt vous retrouvez
seul qui est normal et là c'est la
déprime et là je me me drague à la télé
oui je le reconnais vous devenez assez
que ces crabes avec muriel schéma face
gros qu'on la fasse gros con c'est à
dire que tout est dû c'est moins
handicapé donc tout est dû c'est comme
en centre de rééducation ensemble de
réduit quand on est dans une bulle on
est super protégés on appuie sur une
sonnette on vient vous aider hélas dans
ce coup on vous lâche dans la nature
vous essayez c'est fini tu étais
protestent et des machins aller à la
maison et là n'étaient pas préparés
alors le seul moment de bonheur de cette
époque c'est quand vous partez à la
ciotat avec handisport pour faire de la
plongée ouais ouais le retour à la vie
quoi alors on fait de la plongée c'est
très agréable mais le problème c'est que
quand vous revenez à la main ben c'est
d'autant plus difficile retrouvez dans
votre univers matinée tout seul parce
qu'elle travaille toute la journée
exactement
alors votre coupe se détériore à ce
moment là c'est pas facile pour muriel
d'être à la fois une épouse une
infirmière c'est extrêmement compliqué
elle sent bah ouais sept ans après là je
rentre dans une phase de colère
monstrueuse puisque j'avais décidé de
vivre pour mes deux garçons et que la
voilà le fait que mon époux ce sens là
et c'est une nouvelle douleur cette fois
ci pas physique simplement le coeur et
là j'ai bizarrement là je suis plus le
gars handicapés juste redevient normal
quoi et je n'accepte pas le fait de la
séparation ouais alors voilà le soir
même vous avez une bouteille de martini
dans une espèce de comas éthyliques vous
voulez vous jeter d'un pont il ya un
miracle c'est qu'au dernier moment votre
fils vous appelle vous lui répondez vous
entendez la voix de votre si c'est
évidemment vous ne vous jetez pas dans
la rivière non non il annonce que je
lâche des piges à jérémy où est ce que
je suis et moi je suis tellement péter
que ben voilà avec des prothèses déjà
tenir debout quand les bords mails avec
des prothèses sont encore pires donc
voilà je m'écroule et puis après ils me
retrouver alors il vous faudra trois ans
pour remonter la pente du désir dit vous
ai rencontré susanna qui emménagera chez
vous alors avec ses trois filles 2 chat
un chien
n'est pas du tout cela non non mais non
mais c'était énorme c'est trop complet
franchement c'est comme quoi tout est
jouable quoi j'avais super peur en
disant mais qui va être capable de
m'aimer pas de bras pas de gens quoi
c'est impossible cette histoire et puis
bah j'ai tenté ma chance sur internet
sur internet
hélas une incroyable idée vous vient
votre mise afin saut en parachute 5000 m
en chute libre et à l'arrivée quand un
journaliste lui demande quel est votre
prochain défi vous répondais je vais
traverser la manche à la nage voilà et
là je demande la susanna si elle est
d'accord et puis même dit et c'est quoi
la traversée de la manche belge il n'en
sait pas plus que toi j'ai vu ça à la
télé il ya 14 ans aumônier d'hôpital ray
et on rentre à la maison et on regarde
sur internet mon dieu 34km température
de l'eau 14° taux de réussite chez les
valides 10% mais j dans quoi je me suis
embarqué c'est trop tard c'était parti
fallait y aller quoi saisit alors vous
trouvez une entrée 2 s'appelle valérie
carbonel
incroyable bonne femme là vous commencez
à vous entraîner même si inhumain
évidemment ouais bah oui mais premier 25
m g que j'allais mourir mais tu es
souffler le curve explorer à vous dites
je pleurais douleur mais j'ai retourné
le lendemain ouais c'est le jeu alors au
bout d'un an vous stagné un peu à trois
heures de nage par jour est la solution
consistera à changer les prothèses ouais
ouais les premières prothèses dire que
de prendre d'exploiter ou elf le tfc 3
kg il a émis de la mousse expansée
c'était mon prothésiste un caviar au
pied levé rapidos et puis mais avant que
les ingénieurs travaille vraiment dessus
et ainsi de suite il a fallu way est
presque un an en bout de deux ans vous
nagez neuf heures d'affilée ouais je
rentre à 8 heures le matin dans la
piscine ce soir à 18 heures alors pour
vous endurcir la coach valérie vous
concocte une épreuve noirmoutier et
pornic noirmoutier en douze heures ouais
à lire au toit vous le faites en 10
heures oui elle allait pas contente a
dit je t'ai demandé 12 heures ce n'est
pas marc délire tu retournes et vous
avez refait deux heures j'ai tourné en
rond devant le port
je pouvais pas rentrer et le 18
septembre 2010 vous mettez à l'eau sur
la plage de folkestone dans le sud de
l'angleterre compliqué parce qu'au
départ il vous faut déjà presque deux
heures pour arriver à l'ordre le nar
là tout le monde a peur on dit merci et
c'est cuit quoi il veut pas y arriver
c'est mort arrive au mieux la traversée
vous vomissez de fatigue et de froid
vous dites c'est le fameux passage à
vide ouais j'ai trop ralenti je le froid
m'attaque j'ai les colis que j'ai mal au
dos j'ai mal au ventre suis pas bien et
là dans ma tête tout de suite dit non si
c'est pas possible quoi il ya plein de
gens qui t'ont fait confiance mongrain
au début tu es tout seul dans cette idée
à la noix et mais après il ya plus de
200 personnes qui tombent et des
verrières de plus de 200 personnes voie
verte naj et là je me mets à nager mais
comme j'ai jamais nagé de ma vie quoi
j'étais en pulsations à 130-140 tout le
long là je suis monté à 170 180 pendant
20 à 25 minutes jacques d'un côté arnaud
de l'hôte et gueuler tous les deux à
droite à gauche en pleine nuit on voyait
rien et on fonce sur le cap gris nez et
l'huissier qui lui a été super calme au
début c'était trop drôle que jamais
ouais je suis ici je suis là pour
constater et à la fin de la traversée
c'est dégueu le plus fort est
comme un malade
alors là maintenant attendez il ya le
prochain défi alors si réunir les cinq
continents à la nage avoir d'abord vous
faites papouasie en indonésie pour
réunir l'océanie à la vie à l'asie ça
fait combien cela peut paraît pas prêt à
25 bornes a quand même un prêt de
jordanie egypte donc pareil 20 à 25 km
en signe espagne maroc pour relier
l'afrique à l'europe si détroit de
gibraltar là ça se complique là ça
devient très dur ce que gibraltar s'est
vraiment l'atlantique qui remplit bassin
méditerranéen et là il ya des vagues
dans tous les sens un centre aux chocs
et tout il ya un bon entraîneur donc là
ça va vraiment se corse et aaron est
très dur et la distance est plus courte
en revanche voilà on a quatorze
kilomètres à vol d'oiseau mais avec les
courants le vent on va faire après 25 en
pareil cas et puis à la nascar dont
russie à la mairie non mais c'est déjà
bien les 3t pas obligé de la faire
là on est fait très froid là on entre 0
et 3 degrés est là
on va nager après six kilomètres donc 2h
2h30 et là on s'est vraiment entraîné à
font romeu comme des fous dans un lac
qui venait de dégeler on a nagé pendant
quinze jours là haut à forum me préparer
en globules rouges ainsi de suite et
puis moi et arnaud par exemple quand on
prend un bain ouais les glaces on l'aimé
pas un apéro non les maires la baignoire
on prend des bains avec des glaçons pas
vrai pour vraiment préparer le corps le
au froid y'a pas susan lendemain non là
non elle n'est pas d'accord
jusqu'ici l'exploit de relier les cinq
continents il ya qu un seul mec est
arrivé valide marque diaz way est là
mais moi je voulais pas le faire tout
seul je voulais faire avec un agent
valide un nageur valide un agents
handicapés tout les 2 reliant
symboliquement les cinq continents ça
veut dire qu'on n'est pas si loin les
uns les autres on se ressemble à tous il
est tous capable de faire la même chose
ya pas de différence
[Applaudissements]
ça commence quand le 6 mai la à huawei
en votes le matin on va nager un petit
peu à 20h on a le résultat 23 heures et
les politiques
voilà c'était salut les terriens votre
photo du samedi avec steve ballmer pour
le test
chez albin michel xavier de moulins pour
ce parfait si elle veut au diable
vauvert renault solo sur scène avec
samuel le bihan dia 30 watts dans
inconnu à cette adresse le 2 mai
elisabeth lévy pour la gauche contre le
réel chez fayard et si lui croizon merci
bon j'ai traversé la manche à la mat
chez gas et vite salut les terriens
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu